okay and what that lets you do is plot
those on a number line okay so you've
got a couple of things that you have to
do here write a number line is about
comparing different numbers together and
making the order of those numbers clear
okay
so we want to compare them we need to
have all of them in the same terms now
three of them look pretty good but one
of them is out of place which one
wonderful what is it it's we have
language to describe this it's a mixed
new rule and the rest are improper
aren't they okay so the first thing we
should do is write 4/3 instead oh I'm
sorry
that's right um so you got proper what's
this it's a whole number isn't it
because one it's an integer and this is
improper okay but they've all got over
three the mix new rules the only tricky
one now we've got that we've got two
three four seven so now you can get your
spacing right that's vitally important
that just like on an integer number line
right things are spaced out equally okay
so you might now have draw now tell me
which one's the most important non mark
on a number line zero fantastic now
before I draw it in when we're doing
integers we would routinely put the zero
in the middle and that made sense
because sometimes we'd have negative
numbers and sometimes we would have
positive numbers so zero in the middle
but have a look at the numbers that
we've been asked to plot they are all
positive okay so putting zero in the
middle maybe not the best idea I'm gonna
put it over here okay yeah just so that
I have enough space over here and I can
put the rest of my fractions now they're
all over three okay so when I think
about the spacing all I need to worry
about is these the numerators the top
numbers okay so make sure you've got
enough space from here to here to have
730 dots or eight depending on how you
count and I'll make sure they're
equidistant
okay there we go right now you can count
your head you know that you don't have
to put every number in but you may like
to just to make sure that you don't miss
any numbers by accident okay so eight
right now that's just a normal you know
whole number number line but make it a
fraction number line
I just divide everything by 3 because my
denominators here or thirds aren't they
okay so I guess that'd be one-third
two-thirds three-thirds that'd be one
wouldn't it fourth birds there's two
there and so if you like it's just like
a normal number line but your zoo did
okay before it's like oh look there's
zero one two three but now where's one
it something's there you've got you've
got a much closer view okay now we've
done all the hard work you just have to
stick in the relevant fractions right so
where's two thirds there it is three
thirds 4/3 and seven thirds like a bit
of a blown up over there poor guy
alright so let me just make sure that I
got this straight construction on the
line but think about what numbers you
actually got to put on there okay think
about those then George just like a
normal number line everything's spaced
out you've got you one two three four
and so on then add on a denominator
whatever is appropriate to your question
that make sense okay